bonjour bienvenue d'un point de vue
bienvenue dans figaro la dhca rancune
des débats 48 minutes sur l'actualité 48
minutes c'est moins long qu'un discours
d' emmanuel macron on peut continuer
d'ailleurs à succès discours d' emmanuel
macron sur facebook
aujourd'hui le président s'adresse au
maire des élus locaux pas forcément
emballé par les réformes annoncées on
verra cela dans un instant avec notre
journaliste emmanuel galiero qui est sur
place on parlera aussi de la mini
tempête déclenchée par la parution d'un
livre sur la campagne de françois fillon
le livre s'appelle déflagration c'est un
homme d'ordinaire pourtant flegmatique
qui a pris la plume cet homme c'est
patrick stefanini on verra tout cela
enfin on parlera de la libye des
migrants et de l'émotion provoquée par
ce reportage de cnn sur les marchés aux
esclaves des hommes vendu aux enchères
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée un
crime contre l'humanité dénoncent
emmanuel macron la route des migrants
qui passe aujourd'hui par la libye qui
avant étaient passés par la grèce le
premier ministre grec alexis tsipras
c'était ce matin dans les locaux du
figaro
à cette table dans ce studio alors ne
manquez pas son interview ça sera tout
de suite après point de vue sur figaro
live bonjour philippe meyer jeu on est
ravi de vous voir sur ce plateau
vous êtes journaliste écrivain homme de
radio
vous animez aujourd'hui le nouvel esprit
public et au théâtre de l'école
alsacienne une fois par mois et en
l'émission a lieu toutes les semaines
une fois par mois le gâteau décoré comme
au théâtre
en relisant votre biographie j'ai vu
qu'en 68 vous étiez proche de paul
ricoeur auprès duquel vous militiez au
sein d'un comité d'action qui
s'appellera nous sommes en a non c'est
pas exact nous sommes en marche et
c'était pas le comité excepté nous
sommes en marche nous étions un groupe
extrêmement hétéroclites dont paul
ricoeur était le était le leader le
rassembleur des rues n'est pas vraiment
à tempérament de leader
et dans ce groupe il y avait une espèce
de d'extrême gauche n'est pas politique
et je dirais assez pragmatique et très
intéressante qui s'appelait nous sommes
en marche et qui publié un bulletin que
grâce à
auditeur j'ai retrouvé il ya peu de
temps qui s'appelait nous sommes en
marche mais ça n'était pas là si j'ose
dire la branche stricker a calé cette
durée d'origine je vais vous présenter
ce qui était avancé qu'il fallait les
unes après les autres
vous êtes homme de radio également
puisque vous animez tous les samedis
matins médiapolis sur europe 1 mais vous
êtes aussi politologue est l'auteur de
macron et en même temps c'est par grèce
amont chez plon et c'est écrit avec
laurent guillaume et alice beaudry
bonjour mathieu aron directeur adjoint
de la rédaction de l'ops oms qui fait un
pas de côté sur l'actualité cette
semaine en posant cette question faut-il
déboulonner nos grands hommes vers les
mureaux sur l'histoire et tous les gens
qui veulent effectivement déboulonner
des statuts on a beaucoup parlé de
colbert et nous on a organisé entre les
prophètes que quelques grands hommes
célèbres voilà d'ailleurs en couverture
de gaulle napoléon et quelques autres et
vous avez également été l'auteur de
folles rumeurs les nouvelles frontières
de l'intox
oui c'est chez stock alors là c'est de
l'info c'est pas de l'intox alexis
brézet vous êtes bien directeur des
rédactions du figaro
quand je vois les psys macro lmr est une
opération réussie depuis deux jours
emmanuel macron et son gouvernement se
met en quatre pour les maires de france
réuni en congrès à paris le président de
la république est en ce moment devant
eux un discours fleuve comme il en a
l'habitude d'un discours sur la
fiscalité locale aussi en principe avec
quel impact c'est ce qu'on va voir tout
de suite en rejoignant emmanuel galiero
emmanuel qui est journalistes du service
politique du figaro emmanuel bonjour
vous êtes donc porte de versailles
oui bonjour à tous bonjour veaux le
discours a commencé depuis maintenant
une bonne demi heure quel est le quel
est l'impact comment il est accueilli
écoutez c'est très curieux l'ambiance
ici parce que à l'arrivée pour vous
raconter un peu les coulisses madame
hidalgo quand elle est arrivée la
première à monter sur l'estrade elle a
été plutôt sifflet et puis après
applaudi 1 donc on a du mal à savoir
exactement ce qu'on pense les maires
laignel le vice président de la ce sont
des maires de 30 est il très applaudi
parce qu'il a rappelé les attentes des
communes comme baroin d'ailleurs qui ont
été très fermes quand même dans l'eure
pour emmanuel macron à son arrivée
également il ya eu un mélange de paix et
d'applaudissements et d'ailleurs tout au
long de ce discours c'est un peu pareil
les mairies coûte ils ont beaucoup
d'attentes le discours n'est pas
terminée il écoute ça le développement
de sa politique est en train de faire
une pause de pédagogie de la bonne
gestion des deniers publics
l'échelle de l'état donc il c'est de les
convaincre alors oui certains écoutent
sa façon un peu déçu une dame parents
qui sortait tout à leur mère m'a dit que
toi le très bas très bon d'autres en
revanche applaudi parce qu'ils pensent
que notamment ces annonces sur la
réforme et fiscales des territoires elle
va dans le bon sens oui alors il ya
quelques annonces en fait macron est
dans une position où il entrain défendre
son projet il a pas l'air de vouloir
reculer sur grand chose notamment sur la
taxe d'habitation il a été applaudi
d'ailleurs quand il a dit que celle
qu'est la fois injuste et qu'elle pesait
sur les classes moyennes est alors en
même temps il ya eu ces réserves des
mères qui dit attention il faut
compenser comment on va faire nos
finances sont très fragiles voilà alors
le discours n'est pas terminé mais c'est
un petit 6 mais là vous voyez et
entendez rien derrière et des
applaudissements sur certains sujets il
arriva quand même à convaincre son
auditoire et enfin en tout cas un public
attentif sur les images merci beaucoup
et manuel on va merci
ils se les ai mis dans la poche ou pas
les mères finalement les maires de
france ont un rapport
emmanuel macron peu près analogue à
celui du figaro
c'est à dire assez subtil
ma chronique olivier duhamel il a une
technique macron qui est celle de
cajoler alors il cajole poutine tout en
contredisant cajole trump et kajol les
maires on n'a jamais vu cette
histoire-là de recevoir 1000 mer la
veille du jour où on va parler devant le
congrès des maires
et puis ils le reçoivent d'une certaine
manière et toutes choses égales par
ailleurs comme poutine c'est à dire on
m'aide à garde républicaine on met des
tapis rouge on met des trucs comme ça à
l'air et mais regarder d'où ça va mal ça
totalement il a fait la même chose pour
les ordonnances quand il a reçu les
leaders syndicaux les uns après les
autres et les gens adorent ça parce que
comme on est un vieux pays trés trés
monarchique les gens sortent en dix ans
or il a très peu parlé il m'a beaucoup
écouté or il n'a pas parlé oui bah on va
justement écoutez je vais vous donner la
parole aux uns et aux autres mais on va
écouter quelqu'un qui n'est pas tout à
fait convaincu par la méthode macron
c'est le maire de saint-etienne le maire
à l'est républicain
gaël perdriau il était l'invité de rtl
ce matin
côté c'est un sentiment étrange hier
soir on avait un peu l'impression d'être
enfin de participer à un dîner de cons
pour tout vous dire
les maires ont vaincu le sentiment
d'être pris pour des françois pignon
hier soir parce que d'être invité à
l'elysée c'est toujours un honneur bien
entendu mais ne pas voir celui qui vous
invite ne pas pouvoir échanger rythme on
n'a pas vu il n'a pas daigné venir
s'exprime alors pris pour des imbéciles
sait pas exactement ce qui s'est passé
mais ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il fait
beaucoup et parfois avec succès de
confiance à son charme et donc il fait
du charme
bon apparemment hier soir il ne doit pas
fait c'est parce que c'était mais dans
son discours avec les maires c'est ça il
n'est pas fini c'est un peu tôt pour en
parler mais il leur fait dans la forme
beaucoup de charme sur le fond moelleux
la première partie que j'ai entendu
recul sur rien il fait un petit mea
culpa sur cet été en disant on vous
impliquez 300 millions là peut-être
qu'on n'a pas été fait à cette
concertation
mais après sur le fond de deux des
mesures d'économies qui l'annoncent pour
les années qui viennent
u17 mans confiance elles sont
nécessaires dotation vous êtes comptable
d
des deniers publics comme nous tous et
puis l'europe nous attend et puis de
toute façon on reverra la fiscalité
locale plus tard mais il recule pas sûr
sur super pas reçus hier vous pousser un
peu loin le bouchon vous repris là il
pouvait pas parler aux mille apparemment
il en a parlé au maire de saint-etienne
ça c'est sûr que quand on est un ami de
longue date qui lui m'a dit que macron
leur avait parlé or il n'est pas de la
ville et pas de en marche alors ou bien
lui est un menteur ou bien en effet la
macro a choisi les gens qui recevait ou
pas mais je je voudrais aller dans le
double sens si j'ose dire de d'olivier
et d'alexis macron il est en plus d'être
charmeur il est extrêmement physique
quand on le voit ici vous attrape si
vous touchez vous tient la main il est
bon et en même temps je pense que sa
formation chez les jésuites c'est à dire
tout le théâtre qu'il a pu faire lui a
donné un vrai alors ajoutons à ça que
lui même a fait du théâtre que sa femme
a fait du théâtre de la mise en scène
que et je pense qu'à il a vraiment
attraper la façon de théâtraliser ce qui
est chez lui une nature qu'il a exagéré
mais en plus il ya une chose qui est
dans le comportement de maquereau qui me
fait penser à une de frontière italienne
qui était rude bretagne chez laquelle
j'allais me servir elle avait des
produits excellents et puis la rue de
bretagne a été assez profondément
modifiée et cette frontière comme les
autres commerçants de première nécessité
en ont conclu qu'ils pourraient pas
rester qui devait partir et un jour où
cette dame se plaignait à moi je lui ai
dit écoutez on peut être encore faire
quelque chose écrire à la mairie on sais
pas l'expliquer et elle m'a regardé l
est et italienne elle parle avec un fort
accent et des non messieurs mais elle
mettait d'art c'est fini on a été
concerté et ben voilà il a concerté les
maires alors emmanuel macron me dit on
vient d'annoncer qu'il
n'obligerait pas au regroupement des
communes c'est une des parmi les
annonces qu'il a faites
mathieu il recule pas effectivement sur
ce qui doit dire au maire je ne sais pas
il faut attendre qu'il ait fini parler
mais je crois que ce qui est serti
cajole week-end je le palais mercer il
est bien il est doué jouer au théâtre
mais je pense qu'il est quand même
confronté à une vraie difficulté parce
que cette histoire de taxe d'habitation
d'impôts locaux sesquières c'est ce qui
a le plus frappé et marqué dans la
campagne
il ya des études qui l'ont très bien
montré à partir du moment où il a
commencé à émettre cette proposition
europe
il a remonté dans les sondages à un
moment où il était un petit peu faible
il s'est mis tout d'un coup à grimper il
ya des études les mêmes études qui ont
prouvé que ce sont dans les villes où
effectivement l'état que la taxe
d'habitation était la plus élevée qui
emmanuel macron a fait des scores plus
élevés qu'ailleurs
donc cette affaire de taxe d'habitation
ses centrales pour les électeurs sauf
que aujourd'hui alors je ne suis pas un
spécialiste en fiscalité locale mais je
voudrais bien savoir qui en france c'est
comment il va pouvoir effectivement
faire baisser les impôts locaux ou faire
disparaître des impôts locaux pour 80 %
de personnes parce que on ne sait pas
aujourd'hui où il va prendre les 10
milliards parce que ça correspond à peu
près à 10 milliards qu'on ne sait pas
donc il ya toute une un débat est donc
c'est pour ça que les maires
s'inquiètent ils ne savent pas
exactement non plus comment ça va être
compensés et deuxièmement il est
confronté à une autre difficulté mais ça
qui viendra après il a dit il a répété
ce qui est d'ailleurs assez jusqu'à
cette info c'est un pot était à peu près
imbécile est illisible
or il le maintien pour 20 % des gens
donc à 20% dès gens les plus fortunés ou
au moins les classes moyennes
supérieures qui aujourd'hui vont devoir
payer un impôt illisible et imbécile en
sachant que eux mêmes pour devoir
peut-être compenser l'impôt que les
autres ne paieront pas donc il est
compris que tu aimes face à une petite
difficulté me semble d'accord alexis sur
le côté à la fois le discours ça sera
compensée à l'euro près mais on sait pas
très bien par quel miracle
et puis la difficulté de dire on
maintient la taxe d'habitation pour
important il est évidemment politique
elle concentre elle impose sur le fond
toujours les mêmes mais il a peut-être
même difficulté sans doute unifiée
constitutionnel qui n'est qu'une
question se pose de savoir si on peut
la progressivité de l'impôt mais là
c'est où on paie pas du tout donc c'est
un peu compliqué c'est la chose et pas
sur ce qui est sûr c'est que si on le
supprime que sur 4 ça si on supprime
l'impôt sur le texte habitations 80% des
ménages
il ya des communes où plus personne ne
paiera l'impôt parce que 100% des
ménages2 cette commune n'ont pas payé
d'impôt parler des collines où il y aura
une veillée à 150 communes chiffre
approuvé une seule personne mais ça
serait quand même un peu singulier ce
qu'il ya peu compliqué mais le soleil
est juste une petite chaussure technique
olivier du rex à cette censure du
conseil constitutionnel donc un jour mes
collègues qui avant des décisions du
conseil contiennent quand ce sont des
sujets aussi incertain et qu'on est dans
la zone grise vous annonce que c'est
clair s'est constitué ou c'est clair ça
continue on le dit chez nous il ya une
incertitude
il n'a jamais été question que les la
compensation se fasse sur les 20 % n'a
jamais été question de ça benoît sentant
des contractions mais c'est peut-être
déjà à la bleue absolument pas bleu
klein même s'ils n'ont évidemment pas
question non la bonne la logique ce
serait avant d'arriver à la suppression
totale de la pub mais là c'est plus
diverses et 18 milliards la forêt mais
trouver oui après mais bien sûr que ça
serait mieux alors est-ce qu'on connecte
ou pas avec le point de tva parce que si
on si on transfère un point de tva au
département d'abord ça la rassure une
recettes pérennes bray et ensuite la
pour le court les allées milhas à peu de
choses près j'ai pas fait le calcul mais
un point de tva serait donc il faudrait
un pas de plus pour les communes il
faudrait un point de moins pour l'état
répondra comme une roue communiste on
n'a pas encore le moment on ne sait pas
si d'ailleurs il garde l'idée c'est
d'être supprimée pour 80% des
des ménages est-ce que s'il reste sur
cette idée là où comme la rumeur en
courait depuis deux trois jours que
contradictoires qu'à scanner ce matin
qui dit peut-être mais il ya des
conneries on à le supprimer pour tout le
monde et puis si on aimerait que ce
renfort en marge de ce il ya une chose
que je crois intéressante
les commentateurs cherche ce qui va
enfin affaiblir sérieusement emmanuel
macron vu que c'est quand même ni
mélenchon ni dit les républicains qui
vont le faire et donc là on espère parce
que les mères sont aimés des français
c'est une vieille affaire donc
mais enfin quiconque regarde d'un peu
près la manière dont sont gérés les
finances municipales dans beaucoup de
cas et pas seulement dans les grandes
communes peut avoir les cheveux qui se
dressent sur la tête et il ya des cas où
il ya des communes qui bénéficient de
rente je pense par exemple à des
communes qui sont dans des endroits où
il ya des barrages hydroélectriques par
exemple j'en connais si on va voir
comment cet argent a été dépensé on est
absolument stupéfait dans certains cas
il valait mieux le brûler pour se
chauffer donc je pense que l'opposition
entre les maires qui porte la vraie
politique celle qui est près du peuple
et celle qu'on aime
en réalité les mères c'est pas qu'on les
aime c'est qu'on aime les aimer parce
qu'il faut bien aimé quelqu'un quand
même bien sa commune
oui ou non le transfert son action n'a
pas de commune on aimerait en avoir une
et l'aimer mais en fait les maires sont
un peu hors du radar et je suis pas sûr
que ce soit juste
alors il ya une autre question avec le
sait effectivement comme vous disiez la
droite a voulu peut-être essayer
d'enfoncer un coin entre entre macro et
les communes est-ce que ça a pris
ce lexique sap riches et les herbes à ce
que les maires par définition et
défendent leur lors leur leur fromage on
peut pas leur reprocher à eux
il est vrai que les gaspillages sont
considérables il est vrai aussi que
l'état serait plus convaincant quand il
demande des économies au mercy il
faisait lui-même des économies l'état
comme un singulier talent pour demander
des économies aux autres les maires la
sécurité sociale est très peu pour lui
même ne ment pas des économies ils
demandent leur progression quand vous
avez raison seulement soit limitée
avec 1 2% sur un an mais ces bons
français l'idée que l'on limite à point
et sur les dépenses des crachats les
rangs mais c'est ce qui a par derrière
c'est l'axé c'est quelque chose de très
politique c'est qu'effectivement ce dont
s'est on part évoqué puis une partie des
républicains de 10 la province n'est pas
représenté qu'on a un gouvernement avec
à sa tête un président qui ne
connaîtraient pas je le mets bien
entendu pas à l'affirmatif qui ne
connaîtraient pas le peuple et que
wauquiez qu'un certain nombre de maires
eux ils ont les représentants du bain
c'est sûr qu'il ya un côté un peu
centralisateur dans la manière
en tout cas dans l'image que donne le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron de là à
dire que emmanuel macron et ses
ministres ne connaissent pas les
départements ne sont issus de rien on ne
demanderait bien d'où ils sont issus je
pense que le débat est un peu stérile
enfin à parler de cohérence dans le
discours de la droite qui peut pas à la
fois critiqué le fait que macro ne
réduisent pas suffisamment les dépenses
publiques et à chaque fois qu'il ya une
règle x ont des contrats aidés
limitation des dépenses d'un progression
des portes des collectivités locales
hurler à la catastrophe parce que c'est
totalement incohérent pour illustrer le
propos va regarder ces images c'est le
manuel macron france ou qui est françois
baroin donc le président de
l'association des maires de france
c'était je suppose hier à l'élysée on
voit une certaine connivence entre les
deux alors sont que des images mais
c'est vrai que baroin n'a pas été très
loin dans la laque baroin il a fait le
service minimum qu'on peut faire quand
on est patron des maires de france qu'il
faut dire oh
au président de la république que il
faut de demander moins d'économies ou
moins de progrès de ralentissement de
progression des dépenses
il ya là relativement production de
dépenses et puis y'a quand même un
certain nombre de mesures d'économies
notamment cette histoire de taxe
d'habitation où les maires se disent
comment on va de compenser ça c'est
quand même une vraie question
bon mais il en a pas fait des kilos
baroin donc servi de service minimum on
a quelques commentaires déjà sur cette
question avec xavier richard qui dit
emmanuel marc on veut détruire les
maires comme les syndiqués avec les
ordonnances les maires ils leur enlève
les impôts locaux il ya richard
christophe à un moment il faut
convaincre et arrêter de séduire non
rien ce que dit au départ et
marie-claude les communautés de communes
décidé depuis 1992 et qui bougent
actuellement conduisent in fine et à la
suppression des communes alors on avait
cette info tout à leur disant qu'il n'y
allait pas avoir de regroupement forcé
des communes il n'y a pas eu
pratiquement pas de suppression des
communes la réduction du nombre des
communes est infinitésimal on est passé
de notre guilde sont à 35 mille huit
cents comme ça il comme des médicaments
comme le calvados que je corps et là où
le préfet travaille beaucoup et ça il ya
eu des idées considérable fusion commune
mais c'est ce qui va se passer il ya
aucune n'aura qu'une obligation sauf que
ras tellement davantage pour ceux qui
voient la sciotte est plus qu une autre
internaute
en tout cas aujourd'hui il ya eu une
prolifération multiplication c'est pour
lui faire à son sens notre du terme des
intercommunalités qui dans 95% des cas
n'ont pas réduit le nombre des communes
on parle de communes pas non plus réduit
d'ailleurs le nombre de fonctionnaires
plus qu'au contraire saluer leurs poses
très gentiment qui était vrai problème
dont les beaucoup de français ont
conscience ou six autres problèmes
d'ailleurs combien de mairie sont en
réalité dirigé non pas par le maire mais
par le secrétaire de mairie ou par le
directeur des services dans une
situation de protection assez étonnante
et qui lui permet de faire sans en avoir
la responsabilité beaucoup de prendre
beaucoup de décisions pas tout
exceptionnellement son sac comme elle
vivait à madiba livrés seront pas
contents dans un communiqué venue de la
300 habitants
25 heures de bus amont de 88 ans elle a
fusionné
on la faisait ou la suède
moralement c'est pas plaisir je peux pas
donner son nom mais ça me fait pas
plaisir et c'est un cran si le noyer les
taquineries barreaux sa perfection pour
les marsouins de rien mais ça fait des
décisions martin lemay nous et 80
habitants absorbée par les barreaux il
s'appelle comment bah ça s'appelle
livarot pays d'auge il a absorbé 40
communes autour et la plus grosse
commune rencontré ben oui mais non mais
c'est un grand débat dans notre pays
mais quasiment depuis je suis né c'est
dire si ces vieux parce qu'il ya
vraiment d'un côté la logique
technocratique qui n'a pas arrêté de
nous dire il ya 1 3600 communes dans
l'allemagne 36 mille en france est
insupportable il faut regrouper tout ça
et de l'autre une opposition farouche
pas seulement de l'attachement
sentimental mm50 mais aussi avec un
argument démocratique en disant vous
avez des centaines de milliers de gens
qui sont des citoyens actifs et gratuit
de la démocratie pour la plupart d'entre
eux dans les petites communes qu'est ce
que vous allez les emmerder massacré sa
reçu cette petite question dont on
parlera pas du remaniement c'est promis
brm animant attendu espéré repoussé mais
quand même là l'hypothétique entrée
d'âge que ce soit tout ça peut être un
sujet mais je crois qu on est tous un
peu là dedans mais pour ce n'est pas
parce que ce matin on nous dit que ce
sera cet après midi samedi à hier soir
et avant-hier matin avant que hier soir
on sait pas ce que c'est pas un
remaniement nous a pondu c'est après
aménagement et voilà voilà remy diable
c'est pour leur bien compte qu'il faut
adorer les dix ans et pierre est ce que
ces caisses confrères de fond est ce que
la rentrée de quelqu'un comme olivier
dussopt qui est maire d'annonay dans
l'ardèche peu
donner un signal à gauche et je pense ça
dommage mais ça c'est un des
commentaires en disant il ya un
rééquilibrage à gauche c'est une grande
personnalité de gauche donc ça va donner
un grand signe non c'est quelqu'un qui
est inconnu du groupe thomson tient pas
la route
ok et bien on va passer à notre deuxième
sujet c'est un livre choc celui de
patrick stefanini directeur de campagne
de françois fillon pour la
présidentielle il écrit la chronique
d'un désastre que il est créé avec votre
consoeur de l'ops/oms mathieu le carole
barjon c'est aussi une analyse delà de
la défaite et de l'état de la droite
aujourd'hui
alors est ce que c'est normal déjà
d'écrire un téléphone on a vu un certain
nombre de ses livres écrits par des
proches des équipes des différents
persos des différentes personnalités
coco boys bon en plus c'est bien d'être
comme ça à la fois juge et partie avoir
été dans l'intérieur et puis maintenant
se faire le à l'exécution en pensez la
question peut se poser quand on a servi
l'état parce qu'on ne peut avoir qu'une
détenteurs de son de secret de bon vous
n'êtes plus indulgent pour patrick
stefanini c'est un homme politique hors
site à fond c'est un pas très connu
c'est un fonctionnaire de la politique
c'est un homme d'appareil bondon qui
s'exprime au moment où un autre moi
franchement ça me some chope à wigan
c'est quelqu'un qui a de façon bénévole
consacré plusieurs mois de sa vie à la
pire l'épisode qu'il ait pu connaître
c'est à dire la campagne présidentielle
de françois fillon ou par compensation
de ce sacrifice épouvantable il droit
d'écrire un livre
ça ne me choque pas je ferais plutôt la
même distinction va d'abord réel me
choque un peu enfin peu de choses me
choquent et tout le monde a droit
d'écrire mais à part ça la question se
pose plus pour quelqu'un qui a été cinq
ans à l'elysée avec tous les avantages
et les honneurs y attacher et qui
ensuite écrit un livre vengeurs là on se
dit quand même il crache dans la soupe
non je sais pas j'ai pas lu lite de
grands cerfs-volants et ont tout le
monde dit qu'il est très intéressant je
pensais d'autres mais je jeu piétine pas
les gens quand ils sont à moitié à terre
donc
mais pas besoin de dire son nom non je
pense que franchement on n'y a pas de
problème en plus il ya des choses
intéressantes
j'ai vu dans les extraits ya des choses
hôtesses libre d'armes annoncé par damas
qui sort également sur le principe
moi j'aime pas ça libère je lai
passagers palu suis là mais je vais pas
plus ça non plus pour quelqu'un que
j'estime énormément même que
j'affectionne comme on disait autrefois
qui est bernard cazeneuve
je n'aime pas ça je trouve que comme
disait ma grand mère ce qui n'était
peut-être pas en matière de sciences
politiques une armée qui en matière de
savoir vivre m'a toujours paru un assez
bon guide ça ne se fait pas et là des
choses qui dérangent mais votre elle
trouvait que le général de gaulle aurait
pas dû publier ses mémoires d'un grand
mère elle était contente parce que le
général de gaulle avait attendu
longtemps après avoir quitté le pouvoir
pour les publier alors tout comme celle
rédigée mais pour le bruit c'est une
question vous savez je pense qu'un délai
de viduité écrit à l'intérieur est ce
qu'on me dit quelque part
donc il ya un problème c'est que soit on
a des personnes qui ont occupé des
fonctions effectivement au sein de
l'état qui font delhi six mois après et
soit le trahir des secrets soient ne
disent rien donc faux estime qu'en côté
lecteur d'un petit peu de lecteurs
préfèrent qu'ils trahissent des secrets
et nous aussi d'ailleurs parce que comme
ça ça fait des informations voilà c'est
ça le problème de fond après pour
monsieur stéphane unis je crois que
c'est complètement dans notre or je suis
tout à fait d'accord il a bien le droit
lui de témoigner de la campagne et
laquelle il a il a participé ça me
semble pas du tout chaud quand même
parce que entre trahir des secrets
et sinon quel intérêt lu les bouquins
d'albert et il avait de l'intérêt sans
trahir des secrets l'homme dans les
bouquins de mer y avait quand même des
verbatims était un très bon livre mais
avec des verres maintenant ils ont des
revendications français qui liban dont
on peut se dire qu'après tout c'est
d'équations privé qui rapportait le je
pense que me suis cassé par cancer dans
la manière dont il fait son livre même
si je n'ai pas lu en intégralité mais de
ce que j'en ai lu
raconte un certain nombre de choses mais
ne raconte pas véritablement tout ce
qu'il a pu voir loin s'en faut et le
lambda être intéressant mais le livre
peut tout à fait être intéressant
simplement le lecteur je ne nie pas et
abusé ma faim voilà le lecteur ça fait
six mois je vous raconte la vérité de
l'elysée je ne pense pas que ce soit eva
et élise alors il ya la méthode il ya
aussi ce qui est dit un script de ce
qu'on en sait ça n'a pas été un long
fleuve tranquille cette campagne
manifestement de du point de vue tout
est fini
tel qu'il le dit quand moi j'ai pas lu
ou entendu les calculs et on le verra
dans les extraits qui sont sortis dans
le point mais qu'est ce qu'il raconte
qu'il ya de plus intéressant me
semble-t-il c'est l'analyse d'hier
certes cet échec les ressorts autour de
françois fillon
et dire qu'on aime notre sentiment dans
cette campagne que il tombait une
catastrophe sur françois fillon c'était
une énorme surprise d'une forme de
révélation absolue parce que ça a été
pour tout le monde effectivement
l'emploi de son de son épouse et
l'emploi de ses enfants
on s'aperçoit à travers les lignes parce
que c'est dit quand même avec un
certaine forme de 2,2 voilà c'est pas
affirmer formellement françois fillon et
son entourage savais que c'était une
casserole qui pouvait lui tomber dessus
à tous nos maux mais c'est ce qu'on
comprend donc il va s'agir tout c'est
d'avoir une famille quelque part que sap
a été préparé correctement que les
choses auraient pu être anticipés
bref qu'il a manqué quelque chose dans
cette campagne ce qu'ils reprochent de
la fusion section a été informée
beaucoup plus tôt s'il gagne et non
monsieur françois fillon vos emplois pas
dire c'est que ça lui a lancé sa
campagne ce que j'ai compris sans ne
rien dire à stéphane utilise alors qu'il
peut être précis que ça commence en
novembre question des cadavres c'est un
mois entre le moment où le canard
commencé à enquêter france
voilà et puis il ya des choses alors
c'est plus anecdotique mais c'est pas
inintéressant assez dur sur la froideur
du personnage le type injoignable le
type qui rappelle jamais le type qui
quand on doit discuter des grandes
arbitral du programme s'en fiche
complètement et d'une façon un programme
on s'en fout enfin bon en vacances juste
après son élection voilà sa victoire à
la primaire et semble en tous sens qu'il
ya deux candidats à la campagne quand
même les affaires il ya une phrase on
est effectivement avant de prononcer un
discours important je ne me souviens
plus lequel il envoie ses collaborateurs
voilà le discours que j'ai envie de
faire assister via notamment vu
imaginerait ton général de gaulle voilà
vous pouvez me donner vos commentaires
je les prendrai toutes façons d'exceet
je n'en ai rien à faire et je m'entraîne
et je donnerai d'enfer donc
effectivement on voit un personnage
extrêmement sympathique et il ya aussi
une autre question un peu qu'ils aient
soulevé avec celle de ce alors ça
devient très on rentre dans le détail
mais le rôle de l'avocat françois sureau
avocat qui d'ailleurs souvent sur ce
plateau et qui à la fois à écrire à
participer à la rédaction des statuts
dans marche et qui en même temps a été
conseil de françois fillon est un très
grand esprit très talentueux tout le
monde sait en tout cas dans le
microcosme les gens qui s'intéressent à
cette question depuis début que françois
sureau était d'une façon ou d'une autre
liées aux deux campagnes la personne
c'est étonnant qui pouvait à la fois
conseiller françois fillon et emmanuel
macron et après tout et fillon et macron
le savez et c'est original c'est
audacieux c'est romanesque et ses proies
en plus c'était pas toujours ctb souvent
pas sur le même sujet il a aidé fillon
sur le plan comme avocat sur le plan
judiciaire et il a aidé macron de
manière beaucoup plus je crois
enthousiaste quant au contenu et quand
ton personnage et quand à ce que macro à
penser en fait la plus loin dans l'air
de dire que
il joue un double jeu qui l'annoncent
clair qu'il aurait participé au fameux
discours du trocadéro et si j'ai bien
compris stefanini diop lui reproche
implicitement d'avoir ce dlc fillon à se
maintenir ce qui aurait rendu service à
maintenant ça va être très compliqué et
par ailleurs ma part vécu ça à l'époque
l'à-peu-près g je suis absolument
persuadé que le discours du trocadéro
n'est pas un discours ou fillon décide
de rester le discours du trocadéro d'un
discours d'adieu c'est un discours
testamentaire c'est après ce discours
qui décide de rester donc quand bien
même sur aurait participé à ce discours
ce discours était un discours des deux
graves la thèse totalement qu'est-ce que
là c'est le trocadéro ça c'est très
mauvais pour fuir n'importe quoi on est
vraiment dans un état de fébrilité
absolument complet y ait quelqu'un pour
penser d'une bannière aussi froid d'un
jeu de billard dix sept banques dans
lequel je dis ça et à ce moment là et la
cheville est chère à ça franchement bon
on peut comprendre que monsieur stéphane
à dix et quelques tristesse quelques
amertumes qu'elle que c'est pas la
première campagne électorale qu'il perd
en plus lui-même a eu quelques ennuis
autrefois avec les autorités judiciaires
à torres aurait gagné avec gérald jeudi
à tort ou à raison c'est pour ça que
j'ajoute valorisons passé il a largement
perdu chez lui même pour lui voilà ils
vont les autres jusqu'à présent est
grillé sous toit exactement
mais pour toutes ces raisons il va pas
imaginer qu'il est la chair à vif qui se
met à lui même à penser à des à des
complots mais la barbe
c'est pour ça tout ça en plus d'être
comme ce que disait ma grand mère je
trouve ça un peu un peu enfantin pour ne
pas dire infantile et votre grand mère
devrait vous dire que quand des gens ont
eu des affaires judiciaires et que
soient elles ont donné lieu à un non
lieu soit les condamnations ont été
épuisées c'est pas gentil qu'il a appelé
des années après moi je vais appeler
votre grand-mère et c'est pas que ce
soit gentil au pas gentil mais c'est que
c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas ne pas en
garder pour ben on va passer une telle
impression déjà jeudi les juges jugent
comme si on leur reproche des affaires
s'est en plus 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans après
on va dire
c'est dire lisez guichard
il avait publié un livre de mémoires et
une consoeur de libération l'avait
interrogé sur la très brève période sept
mois pendant laquelle il avait était
garde des sceaux et la cancer lui dit il
et guichard quels souvenirs gardez vous
de votre passage place vendôme et
olivier guichard avec le voit claverie
comme ça du siècle du vous savez je
regarde toujours et surtout le souvenir
qu'il faut pas avoir affaire aux
tribunaux
voilà ce que je voulais dire et donc pas
nuire à monsieur s'était fait donc le
livre qui sort aujourd'hui et qui fait
déjà beaucoup parler du livre qui
s'appelle donc déflagration c'est un
tout autre sujet maintenant leur
reportage de cnn faisant la preuve de
marché aux esclaves en libye continuent
de provoquer une onde de choc hier
emmanuel macron a dénoncé un crime
contre l'humanité contre l'humanité a
annoncé sa volonté de saisir le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu hier toujours un
député de guadeloupe a fait se lever et
applaudir l'assemblée nationale en
évoquant l' esclavage c'était un moment
d'émotion à l'assemblée on le regarde
comment la france pays des droits de
l'homme patel intervenir pour faire
cesser ces horreurs le plus vite
il s'agit là d'une urgence absolue
esclaves a l'air si violences sexuelles
et l'instauration d'un madame nathalie
l'oiseau ministre chargé des affaires
européennes
il ya eu doc ce moment d'unanimité mais
il ya des voix plus critiques qui
estiment que la responsabilité du chaos
incombe à l'union européenne qui a
confié la gestion des migrants aux
gardes-côtes libyens
ce qui a provoqué des trafiquants
toujours alors on a effectivement fait
affaire avec le diable mathieu c'est
très compliqué cette affaire parce que
bien évidemment on ne peut qu'être
choqué quand on a vu les images de cnn
on ne peut être que choqué quand on sait
effectivement par un certain nombre de
reportages et même par des rapports
officiels qui se passe en libye ce
trafic
mais en même temps on sait qu'au moment
où cet été il ya eu ce souci qui était à
nouveau ce est arrivé assez massive de
migrants non plus en grèce mais en
italie soudainement soudainement
effectivement ces arrivées ont cessé ont
diminué de 10 enfin été divisé par dix
en un mois pourquoi parce que le
gouvernement italien a passé semble-t-il
des accords avec un certain nombre de
trafiquants libyen et c'est toute la
difficulté quinqua l'europe c'est qu'on
pourrait dénoncé une hypocrisie
européenne en dix ans ou même de celle
de macron des envois là il parle de
crimes contre l'humanité mais en même
temps il espère 2 sauf que non la
situation elle est horriblement complexe
horriblement complexe
on aimerait en tant qu'être humain
effectivement accueillir et en même
temps on sait tous les risques qui
existent alors il nous arrive ces images
on connaît la situation et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait donc vraiment c'est vraiment
complexe cette histoire on va en parler
je continue avec l'idée emmanuel macron
qui mardi
effectivement disait on peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde
c'était face à une femme marocaine
lors de l'inauguration fin des restos du
coeur on le regarde deux minutes et puis
on en parle avec les gens qui sont déjà
la variété des thèmes qui sont diffusées
mais si vous avez dans votre pays si
vous est en danger un discours olivier
duhamel qu'on a effectivement déjà
entendu mais qu'il a le courage de
rappeler manuel maquereau ou non mais
surtout c'est sallie qui est une ligne
c'est peu dans dans la tradition de
la gauche généreuse et accueillante qui
est une ligne de réaliste on m'a dit que
partage large partie de la droite et qui
consiste à dire on ne peut pas c'est
totalement absurde d'avoir des gens en
situation irrégulière qu'on n'arrive pas
à envoyer chez eux donc il faut il faut
à régler le problème à la source il faut
arrêter et limiter les accueillent
bon c'est macron depuis début il est
intraitable là-dessus et c'est
finalement une permanence une difficulté
plus pour la droite parce que c'est une
permanence d'une lit assez sécuritaire
aussi bien dans les données sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme que maintenant sur
la politique d'émigration il demandait
pas sur les positions d'extrême droite
d'assimilation immigrés égale musulmans
il ya le terroriste mais on n'est pas
dans ses délires là mais en revanche ce
sont des liliacées a assez duré et en
même temps ont publié ce matin dans le
figaro un rapport d'un sénateur
républicain qui dit que le gouvernement
ne fait pas le minimum du minimum pour
la politique d'éloignement des monstres
comme le moment d'avoir le gouvernement
donc on rapporte qu'il n'y a pas de
reconduite aux frontières
en réalité ce qui me paraît singulier
assez courageux chez makro courageux
parce que du coup il encore aux proches
de dureté c'est de tenir le même
discours face à une personne parce que
c'est assez facile de dire oui en place
pour la passe que pour des vrais
réfugiés politiques les autres fous qui
rentrent chez eux mais devant une
personne qui vient du maroc lui dire
écoute et franchement au maroc vous
n'êtes pas une réfugiée politique donc
logique c'est vous rentrez chez vous
faisait il a pas peur c'est la ligne
aller au combat
chaque fois et les français bien ça
parce que c'est quoi c'est vrai que
c'est courageux de sa part
de distribuer les choses comme ça après
il ya quand même des situations qui sont
assez assez incroyable ça dépasse
emmanuel macron il n'y a pas de
politique européenne
il n'y a pas de politique européenne
mène dans les détails on sait que chaque
état a le droit de fixer un certain
nombre de règles pour tout ce qui
concerne les réfugiés politiques
la france n'a effectivement pas le même
regard par exemple par rapport aux
ressortissants d'avenir ont gagné sans
pardon
nous on les considère comme des réfugiés
politiques les allemandes ne considère
pas nécessairement comme des réfugiés
politiques
et puis il y a eu ce qu'on accorde à ce
qu'on a appelé les accords de dublin
donc il y à des réfugiés qui quand ils
arrivent en europe sont comme l'on dit
dubly nez c'est à dire enregistrés dans
le pays d'accueil et on a aujourd'hui
des situations absolument kafkaïenne
vous avez effectivement des gens qui se
sont fait enregistrer en allemagne des
afghans qui soit arrivée en allemagne
qui ont été dubly n'est donc en
allemagne qui viennent quand
effectivement leur demande est rejetée
qui arrive en france
les français ont 18 mois pour pouvoir
éventuellement les renvoyer en allemagne
ce que savent parfaitement ces réfugiés
donc qu'est ce qui se passe mais il se
cache pendant 18 mois puis l'on ressorte
et la france ne peut pas les renvoyer
vers l'île et vers l'afghanistan
et ça ça se passe comme ça dans pas mal
de pays d'europe
donc on est confronté à véritablement
une situation totalement kafkaïen on
pourrait quand même s'interroger à un
moment donné si on a des frontières
communes et si effectivement on a une
politique migratoire ou en tout cas des
mesures qui seraient comme une tombe
certains peut-être en matière de l'autre
c'est ça aussi c'est dire la complexité
de on peut pas de temps en temps il faut
plus se mettre en cause les
gouvernements que l'europe elle-même
parce qu'on peut pas imposer une europe
ultra fédéral qui décide tout seul
contre la volonté de tous les états et
donc c'est d'abord assez assez
gouvernement qu'il faut s'en prendre
même démocratiquement en anglais les
peuples de ces états n'ont pas les mêmes
soient les mêmes attentes mais parfois
même les mêmes intérêts tout bêtement
oui et en attendant il ya des situations
qui sont complexes il ya des politiques
publiques parce que quand on dit qu'on
ne peut pas renvoyer à l'extérieur
contente c'est aussi c'est aussi à cause
des packs e mais c'est aussi à cause de
ces blocages
donc on se retrouve dans une situation
qui est difficilement lisible
politiquement dans un cas la dessus mais
on se rapproche donc pas d'accord
mais je pense parce qu'il ya vraiment la
contradiction quand même que vous vous
dites je veux dire c'est indispensable d
une politique européenne n'ont pas
marché donc à un moment donné il faut
sur ces sujets passés des vote à la
majorité qualifiée sinon on n'en sort
pas ou avoir un périmètre européen qui
soit suffisamment homogène où les gens
et grosso modo les mêmes intérêts ne le
dit alors comment cette solution avec la
normandie quand même alors bonjour mme
aouad qui vient nous dire impôts ce qui
se raconte sur les réseaux sociaux alors
on en revient quand même la question
plus précise de cet esclavage moderne et
des marchés qu'on a vu en libye mais
finalement les internautes ont l'air de
dire que c'est pas un phénomène qui se
limite à la libye c'est ce que vous avez
pu noter marouane c'est bien ça ne
s'arrête pas là libye en 2016 selon une
étude de l'oit et l'organisation
internationale du travail mais aussi la
world food foundation qui travaille avec
l'om l'organisation internationale pour
les migrants 45 millions de personnes
étaient victimes d'esclavagé moderne
l'om explique que la traite d'êtres
humains et de plus en plus fréquente
chez les pacers et d'ailleurs elle ne se
limite pas aux migrants et quand on
parle d' esclavage on parle de quoi on
parle aussi de victimes du commerce
sexuel de travailleurs du bâtiment ou
d'ouvriers agricoles qui sont très peu
payés voire pas du tout et qui
travaillent sur des chantiers qu'ils ne
peuvent pas quitter et un chiffre à
retenir c'est qu'un quart des victimes
d' esclavage sont des enfants entre 5 et
4 5 et 17 ans d'ailleurs sur twitter on
à l'ancien journaliste du monde afrique
et actuel créatrice du site visité
l'afrique
diane audrey ngako qui écrit l'esclavagé
aussi ce sont ces familles qui
accueillent la jeune fille du village de
moins de 16 ans pour faire les tâches
ménagères dormir dans cinq mètres carrés
manger les restes sur les cinq qui sur
les 45 noms d'esclaves dont je vous
parle
62 % vivent en asie pacifique l'asie et
particulièrement touché l'inde occupe la
première place avec 18 millions de
victimes travail forcé travail d'enfants
prostitution mariage est aussi mendicité
forcée pour l' esclavage traditionnel où
l'on peut parler d'achat mais aussi de
vente d'êtres humains la mauritanie est
en première position 4 % de sa
population est touchée et maintenant
pour parler de l'europe
elle n'est pas épargnée non plus selon
une étude récente par des risques
maplecroft
un cabinet britannique de conseil en
gestion des risques l' esclavage moderne
a explosé a dernièrement notamment avec
l'arrivée de migrants
pourquoi parce que principalement ce
petit fille le pays s'endette auprès des
passeurs et quand il arrive sur un
territoire
ils se retrouvent livrés à des
particuliers ou des entreprises qui
profitent et 2 et qui les exploitent et
la situation et notamment préoccupante à
chypre en italie en roumanie en grèce et
en bulgarie à paris samedi il y avait
une manifestation avec était organisée
par un tout nouveau collectif qui
s'appelle le collectif contre
l'esclavagé et les camps de
concentration en libye et qui était
aussi organisée avec le journaliste d
refi claudy siar qui écrivait enfin
qu'il disait notamment au micro de rmc
il ya une responsabilité coupable de
l'europe elle savait ce qui allait se
passer tout le monde sait ce qui se
passe depuis longtemps d'ailleurs ça
fait déjà plusieurs mois que des ong
prévoyez enfin parlait notamment de l'
esclavage dans le monde on avait
notamment un article du guardian qui en
parlait encore cet été
raphaël glucksmann l'essayiste et
directeur du nouveau magazine littéraire
disait sur twitter et c'est notamment le
tweet le plus partagé aujourd'hui c'est
très bien que nos états protestent
contre les slaves l'esclavagé en libye
ce serait encore mieux de ne plus
renvoyer les migrants dans cet enfer et
enfin un dernier tweet c'est un scud du
compte twitter médecins du monde qui
répond aux tweets des manuels macron qui
parlait notamment de la mission de
l'ofpra et qui répondent
comment s'émouvoir de la situation des
personnes migrantes en libye et dans le
même temps concevoir une politique de
refoulement des personnes vers ce pays
par leurs oppresseurs
merci beaucoup mais roanne effectivement
c'est une question aussi qu'on se pose
sur le comment la journaliste une
journaliste qui a fait le reportage de
cnn s'est retrouvé enfin latin prix des
sacrés risque parce que je sais pas si
tu es en caméra cachée dans la voix je
précise le reportage
ces quatre ans vu pasqua ouais ce qu'on
disait autres le savoir que ça existe il
avoir la preuve il doit avoir cette
vente aux enchères en direct
il ya une marge un sujet un petit peu
plus léger maintenant on disait même au
début d'émission devrait en parler tout
de suite parce que ça va sans doute
passionner nos internautes
c'est une proposition qui a été examinée
hier par le conseil de paris transformé
les journées du patrimoine en journée du
mcri moines et du patrimoine
une proposition d'une élue europe
écologie les verts joël maurel tout à
fait sérieuse mais qui a reçu quand même
un avis défavorable et qui a pris en
réponse un tweet du groupe udf modem 10
ans mais pourquoi pas une rue des francs
bourgeois ou un boulevard des italiennes
alors après l'écriture inclusive la
féminisation des noms de métiers
pourquoi pas finalement des journées du
patrimoine philippe meyer vous qui avez
je crois siéger président et même la
commission de terminologie et de
néologie au ministère la culture si je
ne l'écouté ça fait penser qu'il
faudrait peut-être instaurer un contrôle
d'alcoolémie à l'entrée du conseil de
paris et en même temps peut-être faire
une espèce de deux journées nationales
des poivrons et des ivrognes bsca des
ivrognes idéologique a pas seulement des
ivrognes qui sont accrochés à la
bouteille
il ya des ivrognes qui sont accrochés à
l'idée que ils vont avoir
c'est le syndrome dayraut strates ils
vont avoir un tout petit peu de
notoriété parce qu'ils ronde eu
d'énormes bêtises beaucoup plus grosse
que mais en même temps derrière ça ya
quelque chose qui pèsent sur nos
sociétés qui est le retour du
cléricalisme
je dis ça avec tout le respect que je
porte à toutes les religions et à tous
leurs servants puisque ça n'a rien à
voir avec le fait de de croire en
quelque chose de ne pas croire c'est une
comportement et un comportement qui en
plus prétend régir le comportement des
autres et dire ceux qui dans la société
et bien bon juste et vrai ça de même que
les réseaux sociaux fourmille de juges
qui veulent devenir des bourreaux
il fournit pas seulement les réseaux
sociaux il fourmille de gens qui veulent
absolument expliqué le beau le bien
bon le vrai et l'imposer aux autres
comme disait ma grand mère que de cul
leur peine et que les bras leur
raccourcissent après tout il ya moins de
5% des rues qui portent le nom d'une
personnalité féminine est-ce qu'il faut
pas rectifier un peu tout ça n'est pas
que ça parce que se ferait pas ça être
la marseillaise allons enfants de la
patrie
alors là on descend de la batterie
évidemment la devise l'homme je vais te
demander à ce qu'on la cour batista
marseillaise le marché le mariage c'est
benzema raison et la france le franc
pourquoi c'est pourquoi un liberté
marianne le bail fraternité c'est
choquant sororité liberté égalité seront
réservés au conseil de paris et qui
bloque pas les voies sur berge donc à
tout prendre je préfère ça qui me paraît
quand même assez poétique parce que ça
nous permet de rigoler d'avoir
d'imaginer des trucs toujours pas
répondu à l'enquêté que 5% des tendres
eu conscience écolo et après vous
enchaînez avec un truc plus sérieux donc
conseille juste ou d'appareils réponse à
ma question c'est tout ça décoiffe je te
jette rien c'est une proposition je
crois qu'ils émanent alors le thème
d'hier devrait vibrer nom de rue ou dans
des lieux je suis persuadé qu anne
hidalgo mais beaucoup de noms de rues de
femmes mois sauf que ceux des petites
rues parce que les grandes rues elle est
malade alors il faudrait des baptisés
les grandes
je suis passé à chercher la justice dont
le nom de baptême des rues et des places
savez où est la rue colbert un pull bear
c'est avec l'albert pour les raisons de
l'esclavagisme mais qui es tu es dans
l'exemple mon avis totalement absurde
mais bon mais la rue colbert études rue
absolument minuscule extrêmement étroite
qui est derrière la bibliothèque
nationale et qui est la moitié en
largeur et en longueur sinon le tiers de
la rue vivienne dans laquelle elle donne
et personne n'est capable de dire et
pourquoi la rue mollien la pleine gloire
ces femmes de ménage pas pour jouer les
faux culs même si je vais faire un peu
j'imagine en ce moment un certain nombre
de jeunes femmes internautes qui nous
regardent qui nous voient mais à part
variable tous autant que nous sommes
sommes autour de ce plateau en train de
rigoler à quelque chose qui
effectivement ne paraît pas très sérieux
et qui doit se dire oui d'accord
peut-être mais enfin ces hommes ils sont
gentils mais faudrait peut-être quand
même qu'ils pensent à faire quelque
chose donc ce qui est intéressant c'est
que derrière ce qui est semble être un
excellent voilà et tout ce qui est
excessif est un peu ridicule
il y à il ya quand même un truc qui se
passe en ce moment à travers différents
mouvements qui montrent une jeune
génération de ces jeunes femmes qui ont
20 35 ans 20 40 ans qui quelque part
diez y en a marre on arrête on veut plus
on ne veut plus on ne veut plus passer
pour des gens fiers alors ça passe par
toute une série de choses à part ça quoi
je pense que si je n'ai pas testé le vix
a manifesté sa réponse que sage et
dessert voilà ils pourraient être
victimes il la cause des femmes que deux
au lieu de traiter quantité de vrais
sujets sur ce qui reste de deux
millénaires de domination masculine
absolument injustifié au lieu de traiter
ces vrais sujets qu'on sorte des gags
comme ça ça est dû par sadek sert la
cause et d'autre part ça instaure une
espèce de guerre des sexes absurde et
surtout ça ramène saraba chacun sur son
genre ce qui n'est pas une bonne chose
c'est un vrai paradoxe de la bataille
féministe aujourd'hui c'est qu'au lieu
de rester sur la ligne de beauvoir qui
la ligne nous sommes tous des êtres
humains fondamentalement ce que nous
avons en commun est plus important que
ce qui nous distingue
on vous nous ramène à une femme est une
femme et un homme est à l'homme et c'est
ça qui est primordial et ben ça c'est
après que je ne sais pas si ça sert
aussi ça dessert toujours est il qu'ils
se passe plus de choses parce qu'il y à
quelque chose et si on ne voit pas qui
est une jeune génération de femmes qui à
un moment ne pense pas comme leurs aînés
voir dispose en matière de médias les
dénonciations de harcèlement sexuel
tenant le même
ce n'est pas la même chose mais il y a
quelque chose qui doit me semble évident
c'est qu'il ya une génération moi je
sais pas comment les surnommer où les
appeler et puis celle de voir mais qui
est hyper combattant très sensible sur
ces sujets la combattante sur tous les
sujets ce qui nous paraît à chaque fois
excessif ce qu'il l'est souvent parfois
ridicules voire desservir leur combat
mais qui dise stop on ne veut plus alors
voilà on peut le voir on ne pas le voir
maintenant il ya quelque chose qui se
passe après oui c'est ridicule
effectivement cette histoire de rue
voilà papa c'est quoi la commission de
terminologie et de néologie tunisien la
culture de en dieu seconde est donc de
trouver des équivalents français des
mots anglais anglais ça peut être
allemands ou turcs pour forger la liste
au débat anglais qui arrive par exemple
dans les piscines quand on met un truc
autour de line up ici nommé à la une
heure et bien nous on avait proposé
d'appeler ça une jupe mais alors il faut
que ça remonte à la commission nationale
de terminologie et une fois que la
commission de terminologie est de
descendre lisa raymond phal académiques
français ça redescend on nous demande
des précisions on les fait remonter
leurs montel rocha et au bout de trois
ans généralement marine l'autorisation
de publier le visage cette
recommandation vaut reviendrai si jamais
quelqu'un qui parle d'un leader comme
d'une jupe je vous invite à déjeuner
dans le restaurant dans le pays deux
autres seraient invités pour nous ré
expliquer nous donner d'autres exemples
merci à tous les cas tu est tout de
suite l'interview d'alexis type rassure
figaro life le premier ministre grec
répond aux questions d'alexia des fallas
et de fabrice nodé langlois et surprise
pour un homme de gauche d'extrême gauche
même il appelle les entrepreneurs à
prendre des risques
suivez l'interview exceptionnelle s'est
tout de suite c'est sur figaro l'aide
[Musique]